-Thank you for coming back
on the show.
-Thanks for having me, man.
-You know, I love having you.
And every time you come on,
you always bring it
with your performance.
And tonight is the --
it's fantastic.
-I'm excited. Yeah.
-I loved it.
I was watching rehearsal.
I'm like -- I was gonna run over
and just be like,
"Dude, I love it!"
But, like, no,
you were in the zone.
It was great, bud.
Thank you so much
for coming back on the show.
I want to talk to you about this
'cause it went kind of crazy
on the Internet.
You had a recent run-in
on your -- on a flight.
-[ Laughs ] Yeah.
Yeah.
-You were going from -- where?
From L.A. to Chicago?
-Yeah. So, I was in L.A.,
shooting for my new show,
"The Voice."
-Oh, yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And I've been out there
for about a month-and-a-half.
And me and my oldest daughter,
we were headed back to Chicago
and got on this flight
and, you know, in a rush.
And we get on the plane,
we realize that our seats
aren't together.
And so, I'm kind of, like,
doing the awkward dad,
standing around, like,
not trying to ask everybody,
but kind of like, you know --
But before I could --
-"Can we shuffle these seats?"
Yeah, I want to sit
next to my daughter," yeah.
-But before I could even, like,
make the suggestion,
this kind older gentleman
gets up, and he's like,
"The girl can have my seat."
And I looked him in his face,
and I'm like,
"Are you Martin Short?"
[ Laughter ]
And it was Martin Short!
It was the Martin Short!
It was the real Martin Short.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I love that dude!
-That was so cool.
He's amazing.
-I love that dude!
-No, I love him, too!
My daughter loves him
'cause he's in
"The Santa Clause 3,"
the best --
[ Laughter ]
The best Santa Claus
in the "Santa Clause" franchise.
-The best in the franchise.
-Yeah.
-Did you -- did you freak out
a little bit?
-I -- I super freaked out.
I almost told him
that it was fine and that
I would just sit next to him.
Kensli would be --
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, "I was --
I want to sit next to you
and talk to you all flight."
-No, man, it was cool.
He was really, really nice.
And I don't think
he knows who I am.
So, I think he just did it --
Which is hilarious, but also,
it's like,
"That's a really kind gesture,"
you know what I mean?
-Yeah, he's a good dude.
-Yeah.
-He's good like that.
Are you a talker on a flight,
or are you just quiet?
-If I'm sitting next
to Martin Short,
I'd be a talker, for sure.
[ Laughter ]
I got scripts, man.
Like, I'll --
[ Laughter ]
-I remember I was on a flight
with Mandy Patinkin,
and he was --
I just found him so interesting.
And I was -- and I couldn't
stop talking to him.
And I could tell
he was getting annoyed.
[ Laughter ]
He goes like --
But I was, like, talking about
"SNL" days and Belushi,
and all of sudden, he was like,
"What? What?"
[ Laughter ]
"What's it --"
Like, he wasn't behind me.
He didn't even
have headphones in.
He was just doing this
with his ear.
Yeah, he did not want
to talk to me at all.
I also saw this tweet,
and I would like a little
explanation on this.
-You do follow me.
-Okay -- I do.
[ Laughter ]
"Day one of trying to get
Target and Pizza Hut
to squash the beef."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-What are you --
What are you talking about?
-I can't be the only person
that's noticing this.
Do you guys not remember a time
where you used to go to Target
and you would have a cart
in one hand
and a personal pep pizza
in the other hand?
[ Cheers and applause ]
What's going on, Target?
Like, I just feel like they --
I don't know.
There's, like,
a silent beef going on.
I just would like them to --
And I have no problem
with Starbucks, too.
I think that they're great.
-Oh, it's Starbucks now.
-Yeah. They have, like --
They got, like,
croissants and hot drinks.
And I love Starbucks, again.
'Cause I don't -- you know.
-But when you're shopping
at Target, you want your pep.
-Yeah, and I just can't --
I find -- it's just
a little empty feeling
when you go there and you can't.
[ Laughter ]
-By the way, how much fun
is Target, by the way?
I --
-Target's amazing.
-I didn't know anything about
Target until, like,
a couple years ago,
and someone's like,
"Dude, you gotta go.
It's a whole deal."
-No, Target's got --
they've got everything.
They've got household
appliances.
They got produce.
-They got a D.J.
-They got the DVD --
They got a D.J.?
-I don't know. Someone --
-Oh, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Sounds like the club now.
-They've got great music
playing.
I was, like,
dancing down the aisle.
I'm like --
-No, it's fire.
-I loved it.
I didn't want to leave Target.
-Yeah. Before I give them
all this free promotion...
[ Laughter ]
-Sorry, no, yeah.
Not a paid ad.
No, yeah, yeah.
They got --
Other stores are good, too.
Yeah. I love --
[ Laughter ]
I love Kohl's.
I love -- yeah, yeah.
I love all those.
And Domino's pizza is good, too.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, we don't work
for either one.
-It's great.
-Last time you were on,
we were talking about this
Black Star Line Festival...
-Yeah.
-...that you put on in Ghana.
-In Ghana, in West Africa, yes.
-You were -- you were like,
"Dude, I don't know if
I'm gonna pull this off,
or what's gonna go down."
Did you pull it off?
-We -- yeah, we --
It was very successful.
The Black Star Line Fest.
-Look at this.
That -- how many people --
[ Cheers and applause ]
How many people showed up?
-No, it was magical.
50,000 people --
52,000 people.
-Showed up.
-Largest --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Largest concert
in the history of Ghana.
And it was really --
it was way deeper than, like,
trying to do a festival.
It was an opportunity for,
like --
for Black people
from around the world
to get opportunity
to be together
and commune safely and, like,
have some good music.
It was a free concert.
-Yeah.
-Dave Chappelle, Erykah Badu,
T-Pain.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's a --
It was a big deal, man.
-Yeah.
-You pulled it off.
-No, thank you, man.
-Would you --
Would you ever do another one?
-I am.
I'm actually looking
to do it again in January.
Myself and Vic Mensa are looking
to do it again next year.
We're actually thinking about
hosting the next one
in Kingston, Jamaica.
And -- And we're --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Really?
-Yeah.
We're still -- we're still
working it out in our heads.
And we love the city
of Accra and --
and Ghana and West Africa
as a whole.
And we want to just continue to,
like, create community
in other spaces and, like --
and not make it such a, like,
you know, stagnant thing.
And so, we're just looking,
like -- for any countries
that want to host us
and want to host Black folks
from around the diaspora --
-Yeah.
-Hit us up, yo.
We want to bring that experience
around the world.
-Dude, good for you.
I'm glad you're doing that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thanks, man.
-That's good
that you're doing that.
Talking about your "Yah Know."
-"Yah Know."
-You're performing this tonight.
If you want to see
Chance perform, he's performing
later in the show.
Who choreographs this?
Is there some artist
behind this?
Is there something that you --
-Yeah.
So -- no, so it's like,
all of my music,
and all most artists' music,
like, what we typically do
as recording artists,
we get in the studio over,
you know, the course of a year,
a couple years,
and make a bunch of songs.
And when we're done,
we go and find an artist
that'll make the cover art
for that album, right?
-Yeah.
-And it'll be, you know,
one visual piece that represents
all these different songs.
And what I've been trying to do
and learning to do
is collaborate
with visual artists
in the process
of making my songs
and having each individual song
have its own visible, like,
physical, tangible piece of art
that goes along with it.
And so, now I'm, like,
five songs deep,
but there's, like, real --
Like, this is a real painting
that exists.
It was on --
It was actually on display
at the Museum
of Contemporary Art, L.A.,
for about a month.
And a lot of paintings
that go with my songs
have been kind of
traveling the world.
-Who did this one?
-This is an amazing artist
by the name of Mia Lee,
who's out of Chicago.
She's -- She's collaborated
with a lot of different artists.
She has a new collection
at Urban Outfitters.
But she's somebody I grew up
with, who's just amazingly --
immensely talented.
She inspires me.
And -- And, yeah,
we made the record, "Yah Know,"
at the end of last year
and travelled together to Ghana
and kind of just, like...
I don't know.
Just, like, taught each other
a lot of things.
And it came out of this -- this
conversation and collaboration,
that this, like, crazy song
with a lot of meaning
and a lot of history came to be.
-Well, good for you
for breaking new talent.
I like that.
You know, I think that's cool.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I feel like --
I feel like -- you know,
"The Voice" is the lead-in
for "That's My Jam"
tomorrow night.
For me,
I'm very excited about this.
-Yeah.
-And you were nice enough to --
to be on "That's My Jam."
You sang a country version
of "Hot in Herre."
-Yeah, I did.
-And it was a massive --
It was amazing.
I mean, it went viral.
It was crazy.
I think that it might have
started your country career.
-Mm.
[ Laughter ]
-Would you ever consider
doing a country song?
-Maybe.
You know what?
I --
[ Laughter ]
-You just -- you just shook
your head and said, "Maybe."
-No, I mean, I will --
-You're like, "Yeah,
I would probably think about it,
Jimmy."
-My brain is moving fast.
You know what?
I would do it if I could, like,
do it with, like, the --
You know, who I consider to be
the most important country star
of our time?
The incomparable Nelly.
-Blake Shelton -- oh.
I thought you were gonna -- no.
[ Laughter ]
That's what I meant.
I meant Nelly.
I meant -- I meant Nelly.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-No, Blake is actually
watching this right now.
And I was setting it up
so he would feel that.
But, no, I'm talking about
Nelly, man!
[ Cheers and applause ]
St. Louis is on!
-You would do it with Nelly?
-Yeah.
No, he's an amazing artist.
I remember I used to listen
to -- I mean, he made
"Hot in Herre," which, to me,
is naturally a country song.
But also, like --
What's the one?
♪ And it's all in my head,
I think about it over ♪
Like, I -- he's got --
he's got some country classics.
Nelly's a legend.
-All right. Nelly, if --
Reach out if you want to do
a country song with Chance.
-Yeah, I would do that
in a second.
-How -- How --
Let's talk about "The Voice."
-Yeah.
-So now, here you are.
You're one of the coaches here.
So, how is -- how is Blake?
Kelly, I love.
Kelly --
-I love Kelly.
-She always invited on the show.
Blake has been banned
for three years.
[ Laughter ]
The, uh --
But it's you --
it's you, Niall Horan --
-Yes.
-I mean --
[ Cheers and applause ]
I love that dude, too.
He's great.
-He's awesome, yeah.
-And I really do love Blake.
-Yeah.
-He's one of the fastest,
funniest dudes.
-He's hilarious.
-He's really good, man.
-Yeah.
-But who is -- who are you
getting along with?
Who are you
not getting along with?
Who's your competition?
What's up?
Give us the scoop.
What do we have to watch
this season on "The Voice"?
-We all get along pretty great.
I feel like me and Niall
kind of have, like,
a little brotherly thing
going on 'cause we're both
new to the show, and -- and
the younger guys on the show.
And then, Kelly is like --
I just -- I just love Kelly
'cause she, to me, is, kind of,
like the --
-The rock.
-She's what -- I mean,
she's what started, like, the --
she's the reason why we have
vocal-competition TV series now.
-You're right.
-When she was -- when she first
started out, like --
that was, like, you know,
the pilot for everything.
And so, I just -- I always,
like, respected her as not just
somebody that came from TV but
also, like, an amazing vocalist,
an amazing musician.
-Would you ever audition
on a show like "The Voice,"
like, if you had to redo it
like, a couple of years ago
Chance?
-I never did.
But I think that if I wanted to,
I could have made it on one of
the shows, to be honest, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-What would you -- what --
[ Cheers and applause ]
What would you --
What would you do?
An original?
Would you do --
You have to do a cover.
-I would have to do a cover.
It would have to be
karaoke-style.
I don't know what I would sing,
but I'd sing something.
[ Laughter ]
-Uh...
-Oh, I know --
I know what I would sing.
-What would you sing?
-I would sing,
"And I'm Telling You"...
[ Laughs ]
...from the motion picture
"Dreamgirls," as performed
by Jennifer Hudson.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Shout-out to Jennifer Hudson.
-Sorry. You would --
You would do that song?
-Yes.
Absolutely.
-You can do that?
-Yeah, I could do that.
-Could you give us a taste?
-Honestly?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Give us a little taste.
-Um...
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'll turn -- I'll turn --
-Please turn around
Just so I can get in my...
-I'll turn the chair around.
[ Laughter ]
♪ You're the best man
I've ever known ♪
♪ There's no way I could
ever go ♪
♪ No, no, no, no way ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ No way I'm -- ♪
I don't know.
[ Laughter ]
-I turned around.
-No, you didn't.
-I turned around for that.
-You got me to do it.
-I turned around!
Oh, you turned around
like "The Voice"?
-Yeah, I turned around,
yeah, like "The Voice."
I turned around for you.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Chance the Rapper on the
new season of "The Voice."
Take a look at this.
-You are
an incomparable talent, yo.
-Number one.
-And I would love to give you
the platform
to show yourself to the world.
I think you're a voice
of this generation
that deserves to be heard.
And to be honest,
I actually blocked Blake.
[ Laughter ]
-Did you know it was me, really?
-Yes.
-Because your smile
from ear-to-ear
when you looked at me.
[ Laughter ]
I'm really taking it in this
season, so even the blocks,
I appreciate that
because you're threatened by me.
[ Laughter ]
So, I'll take that
as a compliment.
-Chance the Rapper, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
"The Voice" airs Mondays
at 8:00 p.m.
Tuesdays, tomorrow night,
at 9:00 p.m., on NBC.
Chance and I are playing a
brand-new game after the break.
Stick around, everybody.